i gotta tell you the reason i like going
to cleveland is because every time i go
something weird happens
two times ago when we went jacob my son
saw somebody get shot in the alley
it was hilarious okay i know it sounds
yeah it doesn't sound
okay we're walking back from the show
and you know that hotel is right near
the yes
the old that haunted yeah yeah but so
and my son and i have a very we great
relationship
but the one thing we don't do is smoke
weed together i just won't
do it he's he's old enough to smoke so
he can do it if he wants to
still but i'm not gonna do it with him
yeah right so i know he knows i smoke
weed because he's alive and he steals
your stash yeah and i know he's supposed
to be
we're walking back from the um show and
we're in the alley
and the night before we had ordered a
quesadilla from the hotel but it had
come with caesar salad dressing as
and i'm like that is whacked you don't
put caesar salad dressing with a [ __ ]
quesadilla unless you're high yeah well
after that i even tried it and you add
chocolate
but i told him i don't want that whack
quesadilla i said come back down and get
some
food from this place that bowling alley
serves food right across right
he goes okay so i'm up in the room and
my room looked right over where the
place was
and i hear these five pop
oh no and i walk over to the window and
i'm like that was right where jacob is
and i pulled back the blinds and there
was a body in the alley
and i called jacob and i'm like dude and
he goes hey i just saw somebody get shot
i go i know man i go get up here and he
goes
well i'm waiting for the food right
and i go no i go no dude i don't [ __ ]
the phone get
yeah we'll get some more food and then
he's another long pause and he goes
well they're not going to come back yeah
shoulder again right i mean that's
safe right they're not shooting her
twice i love his mind
and i told him i go you're right wait
for the food yeah yeah because they
they said they let them take everybody's
food was it a gang related or was going
on the guy who they were
trying to shoot died at the other end of
the alley he ran away adrenaline
the woman who got shot in the leg by the
way who was there
was a woman who an hour earlier
had stopped and talked to jacob and i
and asked us for directions
so i'm sitting high in my room i'm just
a tourist and i'm freaking out that
jacob was almost shot
and he was right there and i'm already
freaking out with that guilt and jacob
turns to me he goes dad you ever think
about like
if that woman hadn't stopped to talk to
us she'd have never gotten shot i'm like
man why are you [ __ ] with me like
yeah yeah and i was that's hot
yeah i got to tell you i was so freaked
out that night and he was a grown-up he
was
i i told him i go hey man we're not
going to sleep like this but
you're just going to come right next to
me he's on another level of high walk
than you are yeah yeah
yeah you look at you look at discarded
couches
but last time i was in cleveland the
weird thing that happened is this dude
was finger banging his girlfriend in the
front row
full on that's aggressive but here's the
thing too
it wasn't like a secret under the table
diddle the best way i can explain it and
this is
is he looked like a dj scratching a
record he was this far away
and he was making eye contact with me
and i was like this that's some prison
[ __ ] like this
is aggressive how do you call them out
during the show
here's the thing so the server asked me
why didn't you tell us i'm like
honestly i didn't want to kick him out
because it gave me something different
to look at
yeah you know what i mean i'm so used to
seeing all you [ __ ] yeah
i ended up kicking him out because he
ended up talking at his table and i told
him when he was leaving i go dude i got
no problem with you finger banging your
girlfriend
but if you talk you're disrespectful
that's when we gotta get you yeah yeah
yeah that's when i draw the line
but cleveland cleveland i love it what
an adventure city i'm going
dude have you never been to cleveland
i think great i ended up meeting one of
the baseball players
cleveland brown indeed the football team
no i think it was somewhere else
when i get off stage at the laugh
actually right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son